And the car hierarchy you've just seen, makes it easy to understand the
concepts of super and sub classes but it doesn't make for a very interesting
implementation, instead let's look at quizzes. In a quiz, you can have different
kinds of questions so it's natural to have a super class question. And then,
you may have various sub classes. Maybe a question where you need to fill in a
missing word, or a question where you're given a bunch of choices, or one where
you've to supply a number, but it might be okay if it's not exactly the right
answer. A numeric question might take round off into account. And so on. You
could even think that there is a, sub-class of choice question. I'll call it a
Multi Choice Question, you know, one of those where you need to supply all of
the choices that are correct. What do our questions have in common? They all
need to be able to display themselves, and the display may be as simple as
showing the question text, or it might have to have a list of choices. Or an
underscore at the right place for filling in a word, and also any question
needs to be able to check its answer. That might be a string comparison or a
number comparison that's, or a number comparison after some accuracy. So the
idea is that, the super-class question will give reasonable implementations of
these methods, and the sub-classes can modify them if they don't work for the
context of the sub-classes. I've implemented the question class for you, and
here is a programming problem that's designed to make you familiar with that
class. So that you can form sub-classes, as we go, go along. Here's the
question class. Have a look at it's methods, as you answer the next programming
question. And here is a demo program, in which I want you to fill in some
details. Make a question object, and then there is a method present question.
That displays a question, gets the user response, checks whether was correct.
They're methods for displaying and for checking a response. And I want you to
look them up and call them.